this month nasa's four pound
ingenuity helicopter separated from the
belly of the perseverance rover
a day later the rover backed up to allow
the helicopter's solar array to charge
and sent this picture back to earth
if this flight is successful i think it
is a transformative event for
planetary exploration this is a model of
nasa's ingenuity helicopter
in just a few days a duplicate of this
craft will attempt something never done
before
flight on mars supplicate indicates
she was deployed we have confirmation
that the lander vision system has
produced a valid solution
ingenuity was carried to mars by nasa's
perseverance rover
confirmed which landed on the red planet
on february 18th
after a seven-month 293 million mile
voyage
from earth since touching down on the
martian surface
perseverance has been snapping pictures
and analyzing nearby rocks
but perhaps the most anticipated part of
the rover's mission
is still to take place the flight of its
martian helicopter
ingenuity so ingenuity was designed as a
tech demo to show that aerial robotics
like this
are able to be used for planetary
exploration
ben pipenberg is a senior aeromechanical
engineer
at aerovironment the contractor hired by
nasa
to build the aircraft right now we're in
aero environments clean room facility
i've personally spent thousands of
man-hours in this room
and this is the facility that we built a
lot of the flight hardware that's
currently on ingenuity it's actually on
mars
for the past seven years pipenberg has
been working on making ingenuity
a reality so that seven year development
process uh
involved a lot of fabrication so taking
all of the raw components
turning that into molded molded parts
and so
for example using these kinds of carbon
fiber materials
and molding that to develop the rotor
blades on ingenuity
engineering something like this for an
environment that we've never actually
flown in before
is very challenging there have been a
lot of other
space probes and missions that have gone
to mars and so we have some
understanding of the environment however
nobody's ever flown on mars before
what we do know about the martian
environment suggests that flight as we
know it would be difficult
the martian atmosphere is much thinner
than earth's atmosphere it's very
similar to earth at about a hundred
thousand feet
actually nasa in our environment had the
challenge of designing a craft
without being able to test in the
environment in which it would fly
a lot of the testing that happened on
the mars helicopter happened at jpl's
space simulator facility
it's a very large vacuum chamber that
can be
filled with co2 gas to simulate the
atmosphere on mars
you know it's a really special facility
there are very few like that in the
world
to make ingenuity a reality nasa looked
to a small defense contractor
aerovironment that specializes in
unmanned aerial vehicles
so right now we're in aero environment's
nano air vehicle lab
and this is a research and development
space
and actually a lot of the products that
have
come out of air environment have started
in this
lab so this was one of the first
helicopters
that we actually built and flew in the
space
simulator at jpl this was
just a very simple model it was
attempting to demonstrate
free flight in a martian atmosphere
and it was the first helicopter that
actually did that this is one of the
very early rotor blade designs that was
tested
the engineering data that was generated
from testing this prototype
fed directly into the development of the
final rotor blade system on
on ingenuity
ben pipenberg played a major part in
designing and building
the high-speed counter-rotating
helicopter blades
the rotor blades on ingenuity are
designed
from composite materials so it's carbon
fiber over an engineering foam material
they're very very lightweight and
they're very rigid and that's required
to control the helicopter and to make
the whole thing light enough to be able
to fly
for it's made maiden flight the four
pound craft will rise ten feet above the
surface
so this flight will be less than a
minute likely
and it'll be roughly one story off the
ground
so very simple very benign low risk
low risk to the hardware and the whole
point here is just to demonstrate that
this is possible and generate the
engineering data that we need
to move on to the more capable more
exciting flights
nasa officials have likened ingenuity to
the wright brothers
as flyer which in 1903 made the first
controlled powered flight on earth
a 12 second 120 foot trip
in homage to that flight ingenuity
carries with it a swatch of fabric
from the flyer on the underside of its
solar panels
nasa says it plans to conduct up to five
additional flights over the next month
these future flights will test the
helicopter's ability
to fly higher and longer meanwhile
the perseverance rover will be nearby
observing and recording
the historic flights
you